[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
last summer CNN reporter Caitlin Collins
was barred from a White House event
after she asked questions the
administration thought were too
aggressive as an organization CNN has
relentlessly attacked Fox News over the
years on the other hand reporters ought
to be allowed to ask hard questions of
public officials executives here at Fox
didn't hesitate
they loudly came to Caitlin Collins's
defense SOTA special report anchor Bret
Baier so did this show
the big story in Washington today is
that Katelyn Collins over at CNN was
prevented from covering and events at
the White House yesterday Kaelin worked
for me for years
she's a fair and decent person and I
don't think she should have been
prevented from covering anything
whatever you think is CNN Caitlin
Collins is a great person defending her
was not a tough call then the White
House briefly banned CNN correspondent
Jim Acosta Jim Acosta is not a great
person he's awful ask anyone who knows
him still Fox News stuck to principle
even awful people ought to be allowed to
cover the White House Fox immediately
filed an amicus brief supporting Jim
Acosta's returned to the White House
press pool Acosta got his credentials
back you may dislike Fox News but there
is no question about this channels
commitment to free speech we defend
speech even when it's unpopular even
when the person speaking has attacked us
personally free expression is bigger
than any one person or any organization
it is the very heart of this country
it's the foundation of all other
freedoms we really believe that CNN and
MSNBC do not believe that yesterday the
DNC announced that Fox News has been
banned from hosting any of the
Democratic Party's 2020 primary debates
DNC chairman Tom Perez went on
television to explain that Fox News
simply isn't a real news organization at
the highest levels of Fox News they're
not playing it straight I do not have
the confidence that we need to take such
an important part of the nomination
process these debates and and trust them
to folks who at the top levels are
consulting Donald Trump before they do
anything you couldn't do that so that's
a lie and everyone in the news business
knows it's a lie our news anchors don't
consult Donald Trump or any other
politician before asking their questions
they didn't in 2016 they don't now they
never will Tom Perez is arguing that a
political party should decide who gets
to cover the news amazingly CNN and
n-b-c agree with him jeff zucker issued
a public statement saying so sucker
didn't do it in his own voice of course
he prefers to lurk behind the curtain
instead Zucker dispatched his creepy
little spokesman to deliver the party
line
Fox has journalist like bret baier who
do a good job but every night in
primetime democrats are dehumanized they
are attacked relentlessly by Fox News
primetime hosts it was always hard for
me to imagine a Democratic primary
debate taking place in those hours when
figures like Nancy Pelosi and now Xander
Acacio Cortes are constantly demonized
and attacked they criticize Nancy Pelosi
screams the eunuch that's not allowed
they must be excluded needless to say
ubiquitous windbag Anna Navarro agrees
with that Fox News is it's tainted with
partisanship it's not irrational it's
not illogical for the DNC to wonder and
suspect that they can get a fair shake
from Fox News or if they will be set up
you figured out the game by now it's all
projection everything the left says is
projection whatever they accuse you of
is exactly what they're doing every
single time they say they're deeply
worried that Fox News might rig a
primary debate Fox has never done that
of course and never would has anyone
else done that well let's see in 2016
one of CNN's paid on-air contributors
leaked a debate question to Hillary
Clinton before the event CNN tried to
cover it up then they got caught there's
nothing more corrupt than that somehow
their media reporter kid forgot to
mention that scandal Fox's state TV
they'll tell you it's monochromatic
there's a strict party line really ever
watched Fox News there is far greater
diversity of opinion on this channel
than on any other news channel those of
us who've worked at the other networks
can confirm that conclusively because
it's true but spend a day watching our
programming and then there's and see for
yourself or ask Jeffery Lord who was
fired from CNN for the crime of
defending Donald Trump to effectively
they claim Fox management is partisan
well that's not true those of us who
work here know that but just check
Google for confirmation has any current
Fox News executive ever publicly boasted
about plans to run for political office
nope but Jeff Zucker has zuker is a
partisan Democrat he has said so many
times and that may be why Zucker is so
anxious to increase the partisan
division in this country that's exactly
what he's doing by endorsing the DNC ban
on Fox when CNN says this network should
not be allowed to host a democratic
debate what they're really saying is
that disagreement shouldn't be allowed
they're making the case against
compromise and against bipartisanship we
reject CNN's worldview completely
yes this is a divided country we have
genuine disagreements they're real but
we are all Americans we have more in
common than we don't and that's why you
will often see sincere leftists on this
show sometimes we are tough on them but
just as often we will nod in vigorous
agreement we don't have to agree on
everything to find common ground with
someone this is America nuance is
allowed and you will see it here you'll
never see anything like that on CNN or
MSNBC and those channels people are the
sum total of their voter registrations
you're either with Trump or you're
against Trump
it's a zero-sum world it's ugly and
boring and incredibly divisive we will
never be like that the left embraces
this view because it increases their
power they don't want debate they
consider compromise in morale they say
that they demand total obedience around
the world the left is working to crush
dissent as CNN applauds from the
sidelines
in France right now to name one among
countless examples of it former
presidential candidate marine lepen is
facing a criminal prosecution for
tweeting out photos of atrocities
committed by Isis lepen didn't endorse
Isis or its atrocities no lepen faces
three years in prison simply for showing
what fundamentalist Islamic groups
actually do in Australia Miley innopolis
was just banned from entering the
country
unquote grounds of character
keep in mind that you'd AAPIs whatever
you think of him has never advocated
violence he's never even been arrested
meanwhile radical Muslim clerics enter
Australia all the time
innopolis is being punished purely for
his political views and no doubt that is
absolutely fine with CNN what you're
watching across the West is a new form
of social control it's modeled on the
vast system of surveillance and
punishment that American tech companies
have helped design for China's fascist
regime step out of line and you will
feel the pain big tech closes your
social media accounts your bank drops
you PayPal won't allow you to earn money
online amazon bans your books you can't
travel abroad you're a non-person CNN
won't say a word about any of this they
haven't they cheer you're a bigot
they'll say motivated by hatred they
seem have no idea they're describing
themselves